you rub a magic iPad  a genie appears and this is not any kind  of Genie this is a very a business Genie  and this Niche Genie has one wish that  he can grant you and so he says I can  grant you one wish he says I will double  your business in one of three ways you  need to tell me which way you want me to  do door number one or wish grateful  number one is I will double the amount  of customers that you bring in every  month with this business let's assume  that your churn is not that good so  people stay for on average three months  number two I will double your price so  you have the same number of customers  and I'll double how much they pay you  every single month nothing else will  change door number three he says now  what I'll do is I'll double how long  they stay so instead of staying for  three months they'll stay for six months  which of the wishes do you take the  genie up on